I'll play E4
maybe get some ponziani
actually speaking of Tanya
he's kind of my hero because he played
ponziani in U.S championships
uh not too long ago a couple years ago
D5 is not the most common line but
this position was featured I believe in
Carlson against haifan
or Carlson Hare Krishna
I could get the bishop hair
D5 may be coming
wow what's happening here so D5 of D5
hangs upon
so I have to play something like this
first
both Bishops are undefended right now I
can take and go for D5
there's A6 though so I don't think I'm
winning a piece
oh but there's a tricky line
look at the sign takes
oh there's calcium Queen side though
I don't know what's going on but it
still looks interesting
casting queen size is probably the best
move
yeah I have C4
so there's this pin in this pin I'm not
sure which pin is mightier
what's that quote
the pin is mightier than the sword
but is the PIN mightier than the other
pin
Dole I hung a thing but maybe it's not
so bad
because Bishop takes I have Knight D2
I completely overlooked that was hanging
but now I I move the Knight I break this
pin I defend the Rook after it takes
takes I'm gonna win the night hopefully
unless Knight Def
wait night before
no night before I I take and there's no
time because it's check
dull but it's still tinned
I take on G7
or can I take on take an E4
so what's happening here
so the light's ready to move
I think I just take on if but then Queen
B4 check
I have to Castle you're just castling
Knight moves and I take the pawn
and try and get some compensation for
the exchange
two pawns are hanging light's still
attacked
wait yeah the Queen's tied down to the
Knight
Queen D4
controlling the center
King B8 maybe Rook B1
always retreats
or always suck
there there
there
oh there's a funny mate
so the calculation ends with 94 mates
so if takes here here
so here here here here here here here in
94 checkmate
I'm threatening Queen E8 mate
oh it's so nice Okay
let's go
94 checkmate
that was a fun game that was like a
emotional roller coaster type game
this should be a sequel to my um my
YouTube video from earlier today
so I posted a video winning with uh the
best beginner chess opening which is a
ponziani
at least according to Gotham just
yeah I mean I completely blundered B2
but
I guess I made up for it I wonder what
the engine will say
because White's down a full exchange I
mean it's Bishop for Rook
but there's compensation
[Music]
engine just says that blocks up material
although black has to play accurately
yeah King V8
I was gonna play Rook B1
the king just bolts to the corner
I could have been in trouble
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
uh don't forget to subscribe and like
and comment